hier dans les enfants de la télé il ya
des malades à chaves donc miss france
2010 9 laurent qui lui a posé une
question
il voulait savoir quelle est l animal
qu'elle avait préféré au salon de
l'agriculture
et je vous laisse découvrir sa réponse
est ce qu'elle est trop cage ou pas moi
je la trouve
regardez est ce que vous êtes allé au
salon de l'agriculture cette année oui
c'était bien c'était quoi à bas tout
était cool alors mais c'était quand
elles sont vos animaux préférés à la
ferme
ça dépend de la cuisson ses droits alors
c'est vrai que c'est quoi la première
fois elle mois moi j'adore voilà je
trouve que c'est une des meilleures mais
je pense qu'on ait eue voilà alors le
seul qui trouve qu'elle est trop cash
schéma c'est maxime kenny foray parce
que je trouve qu'elle est cash allé un
peu trop cash
elle doit représenter dans mon avis à
l'ap a dû vouloir le pechoux elle est
l'ambassadrice
le l'ambassadrice de l'élégance à la
française force est de constater que
certaines de ses prises de parole sont
en rien d'élégant tu vas être élégant
avant des choses à dire sans dire je
m'en branle typiquement dans ses
précédents dérapages entre guillemets
elle a pu employer des mots un peu
grossier excusez moi c'est pas
l'élégance à la française il est digne
alors géraldine globalement je trouve
que c'est une bouffée d'air frais et
souvent sujet verbe complément non sûr
que justement ces impôts choses allaient
moins formaté elle est drôle elle
impertinente
alors parfois il ya des petits dérapages
mais c'est vraiment pas méchant et je
l'adoré trouve que son physique au
départ n'était pas formaté et
apparemment aussi son fonds n'est pas
formaté je trouve que ça fait du bien
exotique vous qui souvent c'est bien je
sais pas ce que terre ne saviez pas oui
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a fait on vous
laisse un peu réfléchir oui alors en
tout cas elle est très jolie mère
il est bon est ce qu'il ya des gens qui
me disent qu'il est payé jeu c'est vrai
ça m'agace tombe c'est pas ça m'agace
parce que j'ai souvent l'impression dans
cette émission des pardons toujours
respectueuse que tant que je ne parle
pas ce qui est dit est idiot mais faites
le test est chez vous je veux dire
quelque chose
elle est d'une rare vulgarité là
évidemment la blague était drôle mais
quand elle dit je suis pas là pour qu'on
s'en branle et tous et pas miss france
s'est mise buzz
elle s'est dit j'ai un an pour faire des
bases et des petits clics et bien faits
et chroniques chaîne ou nam je sais pas
quoi avec grand plaisir
mais comment vois tu l'auras une
peinture prend domizio l'a20 prochain
jeu les filles elles différentes et la
france et il représente la france
comment en faisant du buzz dans les
arrangements branlée en étant vulgaire
ce n'est pas la france que j'aime me oui
vous non mais non pardon je suis là mais
je trouve pour une fois elle existe
après les études à son élu on n'entend
plus rien elles sont lisses au confort
sont indépendants qui permet d'y aller
là l'existant à l'élever elle a fait des
bonnes blagues parfois le berrabah ma
foi c'est la vie que toi tu dérapes
jamais tout le temps tu dérapes pour que
si pas rester en france le week end
peut-être ce cas le week end et locane
cartonne c'est vrai ouais ah oui ça
m'est déjà arrivé pendant l'acte on me
dise oui oui bon petit mister france oui
oui outils mr freeze
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]